I just love how I can rustle it like a
weird Johnny Depp wizard I waste more
fluid than right John Lee the video
since you're the best
what's up reject nation is I your king
and ruler John Humphrey and with me is
my underling Gregory Alva I'll say your
name
don't worry thanks this is I'm given the
people what they want today guys we got
a music video to talk about but before
we do that I mean there's rewards here
on our patreon that says any video that
you request we must definitely cover and
put up on the YouTube and today we've
got a video from David Waterhouse it's a
music video so you know what that means
we're gonna have to cut this up so it
doesn't get blocked worldwide I'm sorry
that's just the way it is so if you want
to see the full thing unadulterated I
don't know maybe come check out the
patreon if you want very much
appreciated we got a whole bunch of cool
stuff over there full-length TV show
watch longs for shows like my hero I
could deem me a Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood attack on Titan Gotham
Riverdale and supernatural also tons
more music videos over there from moi
and the occasional G and I think that's
it let's hop into this video I don't
know anything about this group so uh
this will be fun it'll be fun and one
and two come on back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay Wow oh that's awesome
I know one of them
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yeah
man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh wait
[Music]
[Music]
that child actually makes this song yeah
yeah prodigy on the board that was very
cute that was beautiful it's very fun
they're they're energy I don't know
anything about loud baby but their
energy as a family is infectious even
the children who don't really speak at
all this videos are just so adorable
it's awesome they do this for charity
you know
yeah put a sausage roll in the hand of
every impoverished child I guess this is
like a family lifestyle channel more
than anything and they're about section
it says he's a transition from lab to
dad first-time fatherhood the touchy
topic for a vlog I hope he's on his best
behavior if he's still here making
videos I can assume he's not terrible
yeah a couple days ago that made me cry
oh are you moved yeah I just really like
sausage rolls it's finally somebody
recorded why is Weird Al the only guy
singing about food it was because
something about like a stressed out
family and a dad surprising and wanting
to do something really fun and
spontaneous
yeah then you see them like
participating in a really fun recording
like I don't know if that whole
beginning part is rehearse that didn't
feel rehearsed it felt like felt like he
actually like surprised with something
to like loosen up and have a good time
as a Christmas present they gave me the
impression that a lot of these videos
are probably like him being like hey
come here her being like what are you
about to get yeah you know I never done
seen them have fun and just spreading
love and joy yeah I mean loving joyful
stuff will make me cry more than
anything else and just seeing a family
be really happy together
made me cry because the Internet's mean
yeah yeah when you see something that is
just dear and good-natured and kind of
earnest and and fun like there's just a
lot of fun energy that came off of this
like it's a cheeky little cover song
it's a silly topic but that's the charm
of it you know is just how much fun
they're all having I feel like this is
one of those were like the video and the
song kind of go best together yeah
because I don't know how this would fare
is just like a novelty song I would put
on on my own time yeah - but adds a
little piece especially for charity I
thought it was really warm I mean they
can't be poor I wouldn't assume maybe
that studio dedicated their time pro
bono for the record yeah I mean this
seems like a pretty successful Channel
well over five hundred thousand
subscribers seems like whenever they put
up a video they average like at least a
hundred thousand views per video I feel
like I might get a little addicted to
this channel now
yeah man start watching their lives
unfold and then you know start
commenting with advice for them yeah
things that you wish they would do to
satisfy your viewing needs even though
it's just their life you know this
really did touch me yeah I was super
sweet you can always count on David
Waterhouse to send something over that's
a genuine and heartfelt you know David's
a thoughtful guy yeah thank you for
sending this to us thank you for
bringing a little warmth into our day
well Mike I get why David would be
touched by this because David's a father
he's a Family Guy
David's a father who occasionally can't
have some dry spells where his not
seeing his daughter because he has his
medical condition so it always wants to
be with her I think you got to spent
some time with a little rosy on
Christmas I hope he did buddy David
actually sent us a bunch of chocolate
first we got a big box from him and I
thought that was it
we unboxed him on patreon and then we
got another box like a couple weeks
later Oh much more cos so David's a very
loving and giving and generous guy and
he's from the UK so I can imagine that
if I'm touched by this I can only
imagine how touched he was by this oh
yeah yeah
next time David sends us a video we
should all like watch it on a Skype call
so that we can just cry together yeah I
just have like a gentleman's circle yes
sir all right guys what did you think of
the song what's your favourite novelty
song bonus points if it's a novelty song
for charity because that's harder to
find you can subscribe to the Rio
rejects click that notification bell to
get updated every time a review or a
video is out also come check us out on
patreon if you love this channel and you
want to support what we do it's optional
and we'll catch you on the next one
peace